DIAGNOSIS.
>> WE'RE NOT TEXAS, WE'RE NEW
YORK.
OUR COUNTRY IS HOME OF THE
FREE, LAND OF THE BRAVE.
WE DO NOT BECOME COWARDS AND
SEND PEOPLE AWAY THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR HELP.
>> Dana: THAT WAS DEMOCRATIC
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
BLAMING TEXAS GOVERNOR AND
ARIZONA GOVERNOR WITH THE
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS COMING TO NEW
YORK.
I THINK IT TAKES A LOT OF
IGNORANCE, FIRST OF ALL.
THE GOVERNORS OF TEXAS AND
ARIZONA ARE NOT SENDING
MIGRANTS TO NEW YORK, GUY.
>> A LITTLE -- WE SAW A SIMILAR
COMPLAINT FROM MAYOR BOWSER
HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C. WHERE
MIGRANTS ARE BEING BUSED
DIRECTLY FROM TEXAS.
I CAN IMAGINE GOVERNOR DOOCY IN
ARIZONA AND GOVERNOR ABBOTT IN
TEXAS LOOKING AT THE MAYOR AND
BREAK OUT THE WORLD'S SMALLEST
VIOLIN WITH WHINING ABOUT
HAVING A DROP IN THE BUCKET OF
WHAT OUR STATES AND COMMUNITIES
AT THE BORDER ARE EXPERIENCING
EVERY SINGLE DAY MONTH AFTER
MONTH AFTER MONTH AS A LOT OF
BIG CITY BLUE CITY MAYORS CHEER
ON THE PROBLEM.
DECLARE THEMSELVES SANCTUARY
CITIES AND THAT SORT OF THING.
WHEN THEY GET JUST A TASTE OF
WHAT IT'S LIKE THEY COME OUT
COMPLAINING AND ATTACKING THE
BORDER STATES AND SAYING THEY
ARE STRANGE OUR RESOURCES.
WELCOME TO OUR WORLD SAY THE
BORDER STATES AND THOSE LEADERS.
>> Dana: GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAID
THIS.
ADAMS SHOULD CHECK WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
YES, THE ANGER IS MISGUIDED.
I THINK WHAT'S ALSO INTERESTING
IS YOU'VE HEARD RUMORS, I'M
SURE, THAT MAYOR ADAMS MIGHT
HAVE ASPIRATIONS FOR HIGHER
OFFICE ONE DAY.
THERE IS A CURIOUS THING IN
POLITICS OF LATE WHERE IF YOU
JUST FIGHT OR IF YOU CALL
SOMEONE A NAME OR IF YOU JUST
WANT TO BE ANGRY LIKE THE LEFT
WANTS BIDEN TO BE MUCH MORE
ANGRY ALL THE TIME AND TO BE
ANGRY AND SCREAMING AND YELLING
WHICH DOESN'T ACCOMPLISH
ANYTHING, IMAGINE, GUY, IF ERIC
ADAMS SAID I WILL VISIT THE DEL
RIO MAYOR AND GO SEE WHAT IT IS
LIKE AT A BORDER TOWN IN TEXAS.
AND HAVE SOME APPEAL.
MAYBE BE THE FIRST DEMOCRAT TO
GO DOWN TO VISIT THE BORDER
TOWNS AND ACTUALLY SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
THERE IS NEVER ANY CREATIVE
THINKING IN ORDER TO ADVANCE
THE BALL HERE, GUY.
>> WELL, IF HE DID THAT HE
MIGHT LEARN SOMETHING.
WE CAN'T HAVE THAT, RIGHT?
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S A LOT OF TRIBAL FIGHTING.
THAT'S THE NAME OF THE GAME.
WE SEE GOVERNOR NEWSOM IN
CALIFORNIA PRESIDING OVER SO
MANY FAILURES PUNCHING IT UP
WITH RON DESANTIS IN FLORIDA
AND OTHER RED STATE GOVERNORS.
THAT'S HIS APPROACH TO GAINING
NATIONAL PROMINENCE.
WHETHER IT'S BOWSER, ADAMS,
NEWSOM OR ANYONE ELSE, BIDEN OR
HARRIS COULD GO DOWN TO THE
BORDER AND TRY TO INGEST
INFORMATION BY TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO WORK DOWN THERE,
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES, MEN
AND WOMEN TRYING TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY AND TRYING TO ENFORCE
THE LAW WITH ONE HAND TIED
BEHIND THEIR BACK BECAUSE OF
THESE POLICIES OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE'VE HAD FOUR CONSECUTIVE
MONTHS IN THE UNITED STATES,
DANA, WITH 200,000 OR MORE
APPREHENSIONS AT THE BORDER.
AND PEOPLE SAY THAT MEANS THAT
THE BORDER IS NOT OPEN.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING CAUGHT.
IT IS NOT COMPLETELY OPEN BUT
IT IS CERTAINLY NOT CLOSED AND
IT IS CERTAINLY NOT SECURE.
IN EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THOSE
MONTHS AT BILL MELUGIN TALKS
ABOUT ALL THE TIME THERE HAVE
BEEN TENS OF THOUSANDS,
SOMETIMES NORTH OF 50,000 KNOWN
GOTAWAYS.
PEOPLE WHO ESCAPE INTO THE
COUNTRY WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES OR PERSONNEL TO CATCH.
UNDER THIS PRESIDENT WE'RE
APPROACHING GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER TO A MILLION KNOWN
GOTAWAYS, MUCH LARGER THAN THE
ENTIRE POPULATION OF DELAWARE.
THE PRESIDENT'S HOME STATE.
IT IS A MASSIVE PROBLEM.
THE CRISIS IS RAGING.
TO SEE THIS TYPE OF POLITICAL
SNIPING OUT OF IGNORANCE DOES
NOTHING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
>> Dana: ALSO PICK UP THE PHONE
OR PUT OUT A PRESS RELEASE.
JUST USE THE PHONE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD A PEN AND
PHONE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
OLYMPIAN WHO DITCHED AMERICA TO
COMPETE TO CHINA, YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER HER EILEEN GU.
THAT'S HER DECISION.
A NEW DECISION IS COMING
FORWARD AND THAT IS SHE JUST
WON A BIG AWARD, AN ESPY AWARD.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> ESPN DECIDED TO BESTOW UPON
HER A BREAK-OUT ATHLETE OF THE
YEAR AWARD.
DO THEY MEAN BREAK OUT OF HER
AMERICAN CITIZENSHIP STATUS?
SHE RENOUNCED THIS COUNTRY.
SHE GREW UP HERE AND TRAINED
HERE AND ALL THE PRIVILEGES OF
RIGHTS OF BEING AN AMERICAN.
WENT TO STANFORD LIVING A DREAM.
SHE WANTED TO GO TO COMMUNIST
CHINA HOSTING THE GENOCIDE
GAMES WHILE THEY ARE
PROSECUTING AN ACTIVE GENOCIDE
AND GO COMPETE UNDER THEIR FLAG.
SHE GAVE UP HER CITIZENSHIP
HERE, SAW DOLLAR SIGNS OVER
THERE AND IT WORKED OUT WELL
FOR HER ECONOMICALLY.
A LOT OF AMERICANS SAY OKAY,
THAT'S A CHOICE YOU MADE.
MORALLY A QUESTIONABLE ONE BUT
DO WE NEED TO CELEBRATE THAT
CHOICE IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AS ESPN DID AT THE ESPY?
I DON'T THINK SO.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CHOSE TO DO.
>> Dana: THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
HA